pakistan's secret service is coming
under scrutiny over possible involvement
in the taliban's takeover of afghanistan
pakistan has long maintained ties with
the taliban some of the taliban's new
government ministers were educated in
religious universities there now there
are claims pakistani intelligence helped
the taliban consolidate its hold over
afghanistan
university in pakistan
from here it's not far to the afghan
border
foreigners are not welcome here
the university is known as the madrasa
of jihad
and is considered a training ground for
taliban fighters
in the 1980s the pakistan and u.s secret
services also recruited here for the
mujahideen's fight against the occupying
soviet forces
today the university says none of its
students receive military training
nor are they obliged to join the fight
in afghanistan
but graduates describe lectures where
jihad was openly discussed with afghan
trainers
the founders of the taliban were
educated here
absorbing a hardline interpretation of
islam and a vision for the
implementation of sharia law
the pakistani government helps finance
the facility
numerous taliban members in the afghan
transitional government studied here
but the university director says the
school has never sent students off to
fight in a war
no the university has never sent anybody
to support the taliban and they have
never asked us to
nor have they ever asked for support
from an islamic school a madrasa
none of the madrassas in pakistan have
sent people
rajiv dogra was india's ambassador to
pakistan
these days he researches and writes
about the taliban their links with the
pakistan secret services and what the
u.s has to say about it all
when an american general who has had to
confront
afghan rebel groups
all the time when he says that hakane
group is dangerous and it is virtually
isi
by another name so that is cause for
serious thought and serious
trouble because
then they are getting all the
equipment financing but more importantly
all the tactics and strategy from isi
pakistan's current secret service chief
recently appeared in kabul
shortly afterwards the taliban started
their final offensive
capturing the panchayat valley after
quashing a resistance movement there
according to reports on social media
pakistan is said to have supported the
taliban with drones
pakistan however vehemently denies these
allegations
and for more on this we are joined by
asim salim he is from dw's origin desk
in bonn good morning to you um how
important do you think that pakistan's
madrasa have been in helping
or training taliban fighters
well pakistani badasses have played an
essential part in providing the
ideological backing and as many experts
also say in training the taliban the
most infamous one as you pointed out
kanye is tied to the history of conflict
in afghanistan
it gained prominence in the 1980s as a
place to cultivate the mujahideen and
after the withdrawal of the soviets
afghanistan plunged into civil war and
pakistan started backing several groups
the taliban ultra-conservative student
warriors
emerged from religious seminaries in
pakistan and afghanistan
much of the group stopped grass now
has been in some way or the other
connected
its founder muhammad umar was awarded
with an honorary doctorate the group
spokesperson
is also a graduate of
hakanya
sorry about that to interrupt you but
while you're on the point of the of the
economy i'm just wondering from from
your from your perspective how closely
linked um is the pakistani secret
service uh linked with the haqqani
network
well
the haqqani network is the more radical
in terms of ideology and approach and
this network is directly connected to
the ulumakanya
so much so that even the name was
derived from the seminary and because
the seminary is based in pakistan
experts conclude that the pakistani
intelligence agencies have had and
continue to have ties with the network
the other thing is in the eyes of the
pakistani intelligence agencies the
haqqani network is anti-india or let's
just say that this group is less likely
to provide space to india and
afghanistan in the past the network has
also targeted the indian embassy in
kabul pakistan finds its security
interests more aligned with the haqqanis
the dg of pakistan's inter-services
intelligence agency phase amid as you
pointed out recently visited kabul and
it was more to bring them closer
together
and would you say that islamabad is
pleased with the current makeup of the
taliban's government very quickly
it's difficult to say
um
at this point in time i don't think the
exact makeup matters
i mean if you look at it that way
ashley led government did not see eye to
eye with islam about so that this
changed desired by pakistan for its
geopolitical interests in the region has
already happened
all right that is asim salim from dw's
urdu desk in bonn thank you for that
assume
thank you
you